The FBI has served a search warrant on Republican
Senator Richard Burr for his stock trades
around the Corona virus pandemic.
You might remember that Richard Burr was one
of the senators exposed to making very convenient
stock trades right after being briefed about
the coming pandemic.
But before that, knowledge was public.
An investigation is under way.
Federal agents have now seized any number
of elements from Richard Burr, including his
cell phone.
Recall that Richard Burr is the senator who
sold a bunch of stock on February 13th.
This was when the Senate Intelligence Committee
was already regularly being briefed about
the coming pandemic.
Trump publicly was downplaying it and Republicans
publicly were downplaying it as well.
And a whole bunch of those shares of stock
lost massive amounts of value in the weeks
that followed as the effect of coronavirus
hit the markets.
And Richard Burr was able to avoid significant
financial losses by these trades.
Now, do I think that this investigation is
serious?
Because, after all, we're talking about Donald
Trump's attorney general, William Barr's Justice
Department.
This is one of the most politically biased
justice departments that we've seen in a long
time.
Do I really believe that they are going to
go hard against Republican senators?
I hate to say it, but my instinct is that
this is basically a show.
And I'll tell you what, what the counter counter-factual
would be in a moment.
So.
Okay.
Yeah.
They got to get a warrant.
You have to have.
Already done a bunch of work to convince a
judge that there's probable cause that Richard
Burr committed a crime.
I get it.
Yes.
To serve a search warrant to a sitting U.S.
senator, it means it was approved in the Justice
Department at the highest levels.
But I have a very difficult time believing
that this is going to go very far.
Now, one thing I will mention is that if this
gets to more senators than maybe it is serious
because Richard Burr was not the only one.
We had Republican Senator Kelly Loffler from
Georgia dumped huge amounts of stock.
But shares of Citrix, which makes telework
software.
One thing I want to remind you of, because
it's relevant here is insider trade trading
versus the STOCK Act.
There's some confusion between insider trading
from an S.E.C. perspective and violations
of the STOCK Act.
When we talk about insider trading in general,
you're typically trading a company's stock
because of nonpublic information usually about
that company.
It's not always illegal.
It depends on when you make the trade, what
the information is, a whole bunch of other
factors.
And it's governed by the Securities and Exchange
Commission.
The S.E.C., the STOCK Act is a specific piece
of legislation that applies to members of
Congress and it applies to the trading activities
of members of Congress specifically.
This was needed because members of Congress
could trade on inside information that was
not about a particular company, but it was
more related to nonpublic briefings.
Intelligence related to it could be national
security, foreign policy or whatever else.
It would potentially not be illegal per the
yesI sees insider trading laws in some cases
something that would be trading that violates
the Stock Act.
Important to understand.
So the Stock Act was meant to deal with that.
It was passed in 2012.
It was then weakened in 2013.
Now this is really interesting.
The Stock Act passed in the Senate 96 to three,
ninety six to three of the three people to
vote against it.
One happens to be Richard Burr, the exact
Republican senator that we're talking about
today.
Now, let me mention one other thing.
This is very cynical.
There were many Republican senators involved
in this apparent insider trading around Corona
virus.
So far, it's only Richard Burr who has been
served a warrant.
It just so happens that Richard Burr is the
only one of the senators who allegedly did
this insider trading, who signed on to a Senate
report.
Because, again, he's part of the Senate Intelligence
Committee, which found Trump Russia collusion.
He signed his name to it.
Is Burr being targeted as retribution while
so far Kelly Loffler and the others have not
been?
I don't know.
The Trump Justice Department, which wrongly
summarized Robert Mueller's report as total
exoneration.
That was a lie, recently decided they didn't
want to prosecute Michael Flynn, who pleaded
guilty.
They said, yeah, we're not going to prosecute
him.
And they've now figured out how to get Paul
Manafort out of prison, which we'll talk about
on the bonus show.
I would not put it past this Justice Department
to target Richard Burr and not the others
because of his signing on to the Trump Russia
report that the Senate Intelligence Committee
put out.
That's what we know so far.
We will follow it.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman.